Change lives. Change organizations. Change the world.
You first have to start by changing yourself.
Our students are gonna be facing situations in which yesterday’s answers are no longer relevant.
So they, in a sense, have to seek out new solutions to the new problems they are facing.
Change lives.
When it comes to hard skills, I have been able to learn all about how businesses run,
what are the important things that I need to run my own
business and future.  But the more powerful aspect is the soft skills.
I’ve never been to an educational setting where I felt so cared for and so invested in.
The GSB is an environment where you’re allowed to experiment a lot.
It’s open to people taking risks.
It means that students are naturally encouraged to innovate.
Everybody around you has this confidence in you that you will be successful.
Change lives.
In the classroom, outside the classroom, you have so much of interaction going on.
You have people who start their own companies, you have people, who are film directors..
You have people who are bankers and private equity folks and consultants
but you have just this diversity of backgrounds that really makes a big difference.
My study group is comprised of a German,
a Polish gentleman, Canadian American, a French woman,
it’s just really amazing.
That is one of the most beautiful things about GSB, people from 52 different cultures, you don’t have time for prejudice out there, you just have to absorb.
At the GSB, every student is required to participate in at least one global experience in a part
of the world that is new to them.
So I just came back from the Stanford Tsinghua exchange program, Beijing
I was at a study trip to Kenya and Rwanda.
I went to the Austria, Switzerland global study trip.
In the classroom, you can learn about
culture and you can learn about how Indian society
isn’t so different from the U.S.
And you get some appreciation of that and then you spend 10 minutes on the ground here
and all of a sudden it makes sense.  I smell it, I taste it.
Today we visited the All India Institute of Medicine.
You have to see the crowds, you have to see how hard the doctors are working,
you have to see the hospitals, you have to just see the nurses
caring for the patients and the families surrounding their loved ones that it’s just something you can’t get from a textbook.
It’s very easy to talk about it
30-thousand feet and it’s another to talk about
it in terms of three feet.
When a student comes to another country,
a developing country, and they see the immensity
of the challenge, they develop a much broader perspective,
One of the things that our students are interested in doing
is finding business opportunities that have impact, make
a difference in the lives of, you know,
hundreds of millions of peoples.
GSB experience by virtue of the subjects,
by virtue of the professors, by virtue of the people,
by virtue of my fellow students has been extremely transformative.
It’s really about empathy and understanding of people you’re trying to lead.
I think Stanford's really helped me in that sense because it
makes me think not just for systems
and processing but also people.
GSB has given me a lot of skill sets, I feel really empowered.
What I learned at GSB
completely can be applied here in China
It changes your perspective
on what you can accomplish
and how you can impact people.
It’s the totality of the MBA experience
that really equips our students for a life of meaning
and impact as a result of a personal transformation.